il
c'est un spectacle entre expression
artistique et technique de dressage
chorégraphié par bartabas et l'académie
équestre de versailles la voie de
l'écuyer livre un opus 2016 toujours
aussi varié c'est un spectacle de
répertoire son intérêt spécial de
répertorier le cndd spectacle qui est le
même depuis quasiment l'ouverture de
l'académie donc le même pas tout à fait
c'est un spectacle qui évolue avec le
temps avec les chevaux les cavaliers les
disciplines artistiques divers et variés
que nous pratiquons cette année
l'académie a accueilli de nouveaux
chevaux dont un spécialisé dans les
cabrioles grâce à leur apprentissage
auprès de professeurs les 10es cuillé
maîtrise aussi bien d'équitation que les
scream la danse ou le chant
[Musique]
le cheval c'est méjean dès que
j'aime m'exprimer à travers un cheval et
sur un cheval donc c'est une histoire de
couple de ce couple n'est une grande
complicité lecavalier et l'animal ne
font plus qu'un à l'image du centaure
créatures mythologiques
c'est beaucoup de technique beaucoup
d'amour beaucoup de patience surtout
surtout pas être pressé en fait avec les
chevaux parce qu'ils ont une mémoire
énorme et qu' il faut pas demander des
choses trop vite et surtout mal donc il
faut avoir la patience et l'humilité de
recommencer chaque jour la même chose on
travaille essentiellement avec des
chevaux lusitaniens la marque de
l'académie ses chevaux vous avez pu voir
en carrousel de chevaux crème crime et
l'eau donc doré avec des yeux bleus et
qui sont des chevaux c'étaient les
chevaux à l'époque de louis xiv déjà
qu'il utilisait sont des chevaux qui ont
désert relevé naturelles qui ont un
super mental sont très beau show et donc
qu'ils ont tous les aptitudes qu'on
utilise en spectacle chaque spectacle
est suivi d'une visite libre des écuries
l'occasion de découvrir le travail des
écuyers avant la fermeture de l'académie
jusqu'en février 2017
[Applaudissements]